aquí dibujé un triángulo y sus tres
medianas tenemos que a de mediana v es
mediana y cf es mediana y además al
punto en donde sabemos que se
intersectan las tres medianas le llame g
vale entonces que es el centro hoy desde
el triángulo hace y bueno lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es mostrar que ge
está a dos terceras partes de la
distancia sobre cualquiera de las
medianas cuando nos dirigimos del
vértice hacia el punto medio por ejemplo
si tomo esta mediana de aquí la mediana
lo que quiero probar es que eje es el
doble de gm lo voy a poner por aquí
quiero probar que eje
es igual al doble al doblete je veux y
eso es exactamente lo mismo que decir
que g está a dos tercios de distancia
vale bueno vamos a demostrarlo para esta
mediana y los demás van a ser similares
entonces para hacerlo lo que vamos a
hacer es enfocarnos nada más en el
triángulo
b entonces déjame copiarlo por acá el
triángulo a hebe voy a agarrar la
herramienta de línea recta para que
quede más bonito entonces ahí está ahí
más o menos por acá va a quedar ve y
aquí voy a ponerlo de color morado voy a
poner todo con el color que le toca vale
además voy a marcar esta que está en
color rosa que llega más o menos ahí y
finalmente la que llega acá al punto
medio el punto medio
efe bueno déjame etiquetar todo para no
confundirnos este de aquí mide tres
rayitas estoy aquí mide tres rayitas
este acá mide dos rayitas
dos rayitas y los vértices se llaman
v
bueno el vértice sería en este punto de
aquí es el centro hoy de es g y este de
acá es el punto medio de ahí que se
llama efe bueno entonces vamos a probar
qué eje es igual a dos veces jefe
utilizando esta figura y utilizando un
resultado que vimos me parece que hace
dos vídeos en el cual mostrábamos que al
hacer esta figura al tratar las tres
medianas el triángulo quedaba dividido
en seis triángulos que tenían la misma
área entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
comparar el área de los triángulos
y ag y déjame marcar los voy a poner el
agv en color naranja
aquí está el agv en color naranja el agv
es este triangulito de acá vale
este es el triángulo en el dibujo
original y me voy a fijar también en el
a eje y ese lo voy a marcar le marcar en
color azul ya está en color azul azul
bonito
y sería este de acá en la figura
original bueno vamos a ver qué sucede
con esos dos triángulos esos dos
triángulos pues no no tienen la misma
base verdad tienen aquí bebé y aquí
y de hecho queremos ver que ésta es el
doble que ésta entonces pues el plan es
que no tengan la misma base pero lo que
sí es cierto es que estos dos triángulos
tienen la misma altura porque para ambos
triángulos para encontrar la altura lo
que tenemos que hacer es trazar una
perpendicular desde a hasta hasta el
lado v hasta el lado v tenemos que
trazar más o menos una altura de este
estilo para que baje perpendicular algo
de este estilo y entonces pues ahí
tendríamos una cierta altura h que es
común tanto a la gm omar a hebe vale
bueno lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
comparar el área de estos dos triángulos
pero observa por un lado por lo que
platicamos en hace dos vídeos este
triangulito de acá tiene dos triángulos
pequeños entonces este triangulito pues
podemos pensar que tiene área 2 x donde
x
x es el área de cada uno de estos
triangulitos vale entonces estos dos
tienen la misma área por lo que ya vimos
este tiene x este tiene x entonces el
área del eje sería 2x pero ahora con
este de acá tenemos que éste está
formado por uno de los triangulitos
entonces este este de acá tendría área x
bueno entonces sabiendo esto y
utilizando esta altura y las bases vamos
a comparar las áreas de los dos
triángulos entonces qué sucede con el
área del triángulo a gm el área del
triángulo agv área del triángulo
gv es igual es igual a la base bueno es
igual a un medio voy a poner primero un
medio de la base que sería gm gm
multiplicado por la altura multiplicado
por la altura pero sabemos que esta área
de aquí es igual lo voy a poner de este
lado es igual a x vale es igual a x
ahora vamos con el otro triángulo con el
eje que se lo voy a hacer en color azul
y vamos a ver que tenemos tenemos que el
área del triángulo le voy a poner a g
es igual a un medio en un medio de la
base pero que ahora sería eje y g
x la altura por la altura h que es esta
misma altura h que es la de arriba vale
y eso de aquí es igual es igual a 2x es
igual a 2 x pero bueno si aquí tenemos
el valor de x podemos sustituir este
valor de x aquí abajo para ver qué nos
dice entonces déjame hacer eso va vamos
a tomar el color azul y tenemos que un
medio un medio d
multiplicado por la altura
es igual es igual
a 12 x es igual a 2x pero aquí tengo el
valor de x entonces esto lo puede
sustituir por dos veces dos veces este
valor de x que es un medio un medio de
gm gm x h
x h muy bien entonces vamos a ver qué
información tenemos aquí déjame agarrar
otro color que no haya usado el amarillo
digamos a ver entonces este 2 puede
cancelarse con este 2 la altura puede
cancelarse con la altura y lo que
concluimos es que un medio un medio de
eje
es igual a je veux y eso es justo lo que
queríamos probar verdad queríamos probar
que gm medía la mitad de eje bueno en
realidad queríamos probar que eje era el
doble de jebe pero es lo mismo si basta
multiplicar aquí por dos por los dos
lados y entonces tenemos justo que eje
es igual a dos veces se ve y listo con
esto terminamos con esto probamos que el
punto g está a dos tercios de distancia
del vértice al punto medio y en realidad
este argumento que hicimos aquí se puede
repetir para cualquiera de las medianas
y por lo tanto con esto probamos el
resultado